what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest massive black
clovers story developments including
Yami's new post time skip power and his
secret connection to the demon world
which has just been directly confirmed
by a demon this was a crazy
action-packed chapter that revealed a
lot of crucial pieces of information so
let's talk about it right now if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel you want us to keep it go and
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to animal parole or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers we're talking
about the very latest developments in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned chapter 245 starts
off with Dante and Yami coming
face-to-face for the very first time
after Yami's epic return which of course
took place at the end of the previous
chapter dante refers to Yami by name
Yami suka hero and Yami instantly
identifies Dante as a spade devil host
or demon host whichever translation you
prefer Yami also makes it clear that he
doesn't give a damn about who Dante is
or where he came from Dante made a big
mistake when he messed with Yami's
comrades and the Yami is about to make
him pay for it Dante is very amused by
Yami but he proclaims that nobody looks
down on him and he uses his gravity
magic to force both Yami and Finn roll
down to the ground at this point we
should probably address the fact that
both Yami and Finn all have been
floating in the air essentially flying
without brooms
Finn Rolla to be using his spatial magic
to project his body through a portal in
the air but Yanni's ability to float so
easily without a broom or any flying
equipment appears to be a new type of
power the flying doesn't last
long though because Dante's gravity
magic forces both Yami and Finn roll to
the ground but Yami manages to land on
his feet
and he also manages to grab Finn Rahl on
his way down
Dante is impressed by Yami's reaction
time and his ability to withstand the
force of Dante's magic without taking on
any damage and this is the point at
which Yami tells us something important
Yami says that during the course of the
last six months or during the course of
the time skip he has learned some new
stuff and he is about to give those new
abilities a test drive we all knew that
just like hasta Yami would surely
receive a massive powerup as a result of
intense training during the time skip
and that is exactly what happened
Yami then proceeds to combine his mana
zone with the dark magic spell black
hole in order to create black moon black
moon is a spell that seems to create a
barrier around the ami and Finn role and
this barrier erases all of the effects
of Dante's magic Dante is again highly
impressed that a vulgar commoner like
Yami could possess such incredible magic
power and it is clear that Dante is
extremely interested in Yami's dark
magic by the way my guess is that Yami's
ability to fly on his own is the result
of him learning to use and control his
mana zone on a completely new level so
I'm going to assume that that's the case
unless we receive some other explanation
at some point in the future Yami tells
fin rot to get out of there and to join
the black Bulls on the sidelines as
Dante decides to use his gravity magic
to launch a massive boulder right at
Yami the boulder looks super scary and
stuff until Yami absolutely annihilates
it with his dark cloaked dimension / he
literally slashes the boulder in half
and Dante remarks that Yami didn't just
slash the rock he actually slashed space
apart this again emphasizes the unique
properties of Yami's dark magic
Yami's magic seems to defy the laws of
nature of this world
cutting through space itself
in this way should not technically be
possible and yet Yami's magic is able to
do exactly that Dante is very excited by
all of this and he decides to charge it
Yami with a sword but if anyone knows
how to kick ass with a sword that would
be our boy Yami and the two majors clash
in a legendary magic infused sword duel
that I'm sure is going to look
absolutely epic in the anime don't get
me wrong it looks epic in the manga as
well but together with animation and
intense music I think it's going to look
even better as long as they don't cheap
out on the budget it's important to
remember that both mages have distinct
strengths in this duel Yami has the
power to react to Dante's moves before
he makes them by combining mana zone
with his key sensing ability and Dante
is able to use his gravity magic to
control the speed of his sword in ways
that no other swordsman would be able to
do during the battle itself dante
reveals to Yami that he is after him or
more accurately he wants Yami because of
his unique magical power presumably
dante wants a demon to take control of
Yami's body so that Yami would then
serve the dark triad as one of its
enforcers
but Yami isn't into dudes like Dante and
being interested in him so Dante's plan
is not gonna fly with our boy ami at
this point Dante says something which i
think is really important
Dante says that Yami is a key that links
this world and the underworld or in
other words this dimension and the
dimension where the demons come from the
fact that Dante refers to Yami as a key
rather than the key implies that there
are more than one keys and all of this
is starting to make a lot of sense if
you think about it we all remember that
dark magic had a unique effect on zag
read the kotodama demon the kind of
effect that no other magic from this
world was able to create as soon as the
unique otherworldly nature of Yami's
dark magic was revealed I knew that
there was some connection between him
and the other dimension
including the demon dimension in
particular I mean even his attacks like
dark cloaked dimension slash contained
the word dimension right in the name
back then during the zag red fight
I made an entire video speculating about
Yami's true origins and theorizing that
he might actually come from a different
dimension himself which would then
explain why his dark magic is so unique
and otherworldly about nine months ago I
made an entire video talking about the
theory that Yami might be from another
world so if you'd like to know more
about that I will link that video down
in the description at this point Dante
is actually a bit jealous of Yami's
ability to as he calls it acquire so
many arcane staged mages and Dante says
that this is the first time that he has
ever been jealous of a human
I find it noteworthy that Dante phrases
his jealousy in this way it's almost as
if Dante no longer sees himself as human
obviously we can assume that Dante and
the dark triad members were all regular
humans before being possessed by demons
but it seems that after being possessed
by the demon Dante stopped viewing
himself as just a human this is very
interesting because we know that hasta
clearly doesn't think of himself as
something other than human despite using
the power of a demon but perhaps Dante's
current mind state reveals what happens
to a person after they use too much of a
demons power and once they become too
close to a demon this could be a warning
that the more a human relies on the
power of a demon the more that human
progressively loses his or her humanity
until they no longer view themselves as
human at all this might be just a case
of Dante thinking that he is better than
humans because of his superior strength
or it could be that the demon Lucifer
has affected Dante's mind to the point
that his entire personality has been
altered to reflect the personality of
the demon we will need more information
in order to know for sure but this brief
line could definitely be a warning to
hasta the more he reaches into the
demons power in
to get stronger the more his personality
and his very humanity could be affected
for his part Yami dismisses Dante's talk
about acquiring other mages as if they
were yugioh cards or something Yami says
that the arcane stage mages who are
members of the black bulls are not
objects he acquired but people he likes
to hang out with and genuinely likes
Yami also proclaims that he will not
give up a single one of them to the
likes of Dante as Dante tries to attack
Yami again Yami uses the move called
dark cloaked AI slash to seemingly cut
right through Dante's abdomen and that
is how this action-packed
chapter ends it sure looks like Yami
just dealt a deadly blow to Dante but
come on bruh there is no way that Dante
will actually be defeated so easily
if freaking gauche survived that massive
wound to the torso then I fully expect
Dante to survive this attack by ami
especially since Dante has access to
demon powers with that said I would like
to say a few words about this new Yami
attack called dark cloaked a I slash the
word AI is a reference to a Idol a
Japanese martial art of swiftly drawing
one sword and stopping an opponent's
attack with incredible speed I am
familiar with this martial art because I
actually have a black belt in E I doe
but to be fair having a black belt it
does not make you a martial arts master
I think that a lot of people who haven't
done martial arts have the wrong idea
about what being a black belt meets
because having a black belt means that
you have earned the title of senpai or
upperclassman in order to earn the title
of Master you must go far beyond just a
black belt showdown or first on with
that said I am familiar enough with the
idol to appreciate this reference the I
do is both a martial art and a
philosophy and it emphasizes strict
discipline and constant awareness it
also emphasizes quick decisive movements
which stop your opponent in their tracks
before they can even get warmed up yet
oh is about reacting before your
opponent and taking them out quickly and
efficiently it's also about reacting to
threats posed by others it's not about
being the aggressor yourself but as much
as I respect the Iaido reference and
Yami's impressive form it's highly
unlikely that this one impressive strike
will actually defeat Dante a regular
strong mage probably but an evil madman
who runs on pure demon juice not bloody
likely also a side note but if Yami was
caught smoking a cigarette while
performing he item moves like he did in
this chapter his yo-yo master would
immediately rip him a new black hole in
my experience he Ida requires firm
discipline and strict etiquette
absolutely no eccentricity is allowed
but as you guys can tell I really
enjoyed this chapter both from the
perspective of my swordsmanship
experience and from the perspective of
all the useful information that has been
revealed I am loving the Dante versus
Yami fight so far and I predict that it
is not over yet
I am also extremely curious about the
fact that Yami and his dark magic are a
key to the demon world what exactly does
this mean for the rest of the story and
what role is Yami about to play in this
massive war between the demons and the
humans be sure to let me know what you
guys think about all of this down in the
comments below is Yami going to end up
with a demon power of his own or is his
magic going to be used to open a portal
between the human world and the demon
world which would potentially allow an
entire army of demons to enter this
world in order to possess a whole bunch
of new human vessels is this the
ultimate goal of the dark triad a total
demon takeover of the human world I mean
that's probably why they want all those
arcane staged mages they want them to
become vessels for the demons
maybe the Spade Kingdom itself is just a
cover that the demons are using in order
to achieve total demon domination of the
world they don't actually care about the
Spade Kingdom itself they are just using
this kingdom and its armies to
educate all human kingdoms in the name
of the demons maybe the ultimate goal of
the dark triad is to conquer the entire
world open the portal to the demon world
and allow thousands of demons to pour in
and completely subjugate all of humanity
I am very curious to find out more about
all of this and I'm also curious to read
your takes down in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black louver content right here on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
have it to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
bell to turn on all notifications if you
want to be notified and you don't want
to miss our videos you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell and selecting the option that says
oh you could also hit me up on Twitter
and or Instagram acts anime uproar I
want to give a huge thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
baby R a disciple of Lord we go himself
and I can't forget all are the one tear
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including Ingrid ah a
lowland Adam the world stealers the
school bus Tyson query know a quiet
respect pat a heffa and chris loki
finally big thanks to all of our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Odin Anatole Kazuki alpha do on
hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
cricket XP fit edala beat Ted no Ted
Salter Joe Stanton very gucci jessica
calif on alicia actor levi emperor otaku
and JC c waka if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our page and exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]